did you see enough to still leave this
game and feel relatively good despite
the loss yeah I mean I mean we we woke
up and I thought we started digging in
and playing a little bit with a little
more urgency
um but there's no doubt in my mind you
know we come out for game two
we'll be ready we'll go back and do what
we need to do for our team physically
you know start the recovery process now
break down the film watch what we need
to watch but
thank God it's the best of seven it's
not the NCAA tournament
you know it's a first of four we'll be
okay trust me
[Music]
hey Darvin that some of the matchups
switch around in that in the second half
but we can have three a lot more even
defending Joker shot 80 off him somehow
when did you decide to go to that
adjustment and how much do you think it
keyed The Comeback
well just you know pivoting within the
game you know making a slight adjustment
wanted to take a off as being the
initial line of defense and hopefully
you know rui could Turney making go east
west a little bit more and once he went
up to shoot you know he's he shoots 70
on those floaters those little short
range
chip shots and floaters and hooks and
little one leg fadeaways he shoots him
at an amazing rate scores them I should
say
so just the idea was just to get a
behind him a little bit and um have hay
is that big long arm just ready to
contest over the top of rui and so uh it
was good for us in some segments and
you know we were able to after a tough
first half giving up 72 points
claw our way back into it I think the
closest we got was within three
but you know
hats off to them they came out they
defended their home floor
um
a lot a lot of long rebounds we gave him
way too many Second Chance points
offensive rebounding opportunities and
50 50 balls for that matter
um that we ought to be better in
transition
and uh you know we we can't follow them
we got to be more disciplined showing
our hands when we're guarding the ball
and guarding those guys around the rim
in the post and whatnot
I know it's a standard but they made
almost 50 from three-point tonight is
that something you got to get out there
more or is it more coming out the
passing wins I just think it's a little
bit of everything man it's a talented
team you know it's very few one-trick
ponies that make make it this far and so
you know they're able to put pressure on
you in the paint
um pressure on you from the three-point
line a very capable Shooters uh some of
which are Elite
um
and you know you just got to be ready to
give multiple efforts again as I
mentioned before the game doing your
work early being in position when The
Possession the defensive possession
starts that way we're not playing
catch-up
um so we'll go back and look at the film
tonight
see what we need to clean up
um take a good look at that second half
see what went well try to sustain the
good stuff and uh alleviate and and
repair the bad stuff